or the king coronation you know
just stop it dude
Grand
dude every outfit is a hundred and
ninety thousand dollars
so slow dude
just so boring hey if you watch the
king's coronation you [__] suck
you're boring huh you're just straight
up so boring look at the music sucks
dude
this is like the music that should
happen when you walk into Universal
[__] Studios
[Music]
yeah oh dude I here present you I get
out of here with your dry [__] you know
[__] I hear present to you King Charles
why you getting coronated now
you're on dirty King
wherefore all you who I'll come this day
singing
I here presents to you
foreign foreign
are you willing to do the same
God save King Charles
morons
dude this is a [__] Adam Sandler's
movie waiting to happen you know Arizona
yes I I be the king you know
uh who who
uh yeah I'll be the king can I bring my
cat you know
there'd be a cat in it moving the walls
God this sucks to have to do this you
know the way they walk wind up toys
dude this sucks oh my God bro and they
get you too they get you at a really
young age and you're like this true I've
always said this in this
podcast tradition sucks dude
yes
how much bad breath is in there you know
worst music
worst music dude
[Music]
zero handsome people
looks like a scene from E.T for real
it's the grandest
music of all we hope you had fun on the
Jurassic Park ride exit to your left a
crown is the worst hat
like I I would wear a [__] Fedora
before I would wear a goddamn crown
wow dude this sucks huh like just
straight up
the worst most uncomfortable chair of
all time
I mean can't place it right you know is
that good yeah okay yeah look you look
[__] horrible okay I'm gonna step
back here
so much gold God Save the King
bro it's
2020 [__] [__] sucking three
dude biggest hat of all time
it just goes over his shoulders oh we
needed some oh God we need a smaller one
farting
Star Wars Superman dude
Mermaid music
[Music]
I love it dude
hi William Prince of Wales pledge my
loyalty to you and faith and truth I
will bear unto you oh damn he's got a
good voice man of life and limb hey man
hey man shave it
hey Bubba shave it never had a more
perfectly bald just top
than that guy what's his name Prince
Charles
Prince William yeah hey man shave it
so slow oh now let me put one on you now
I'll put a [__] crown on you you're a
you're a queen right yeah there we go
okay something sucks just make sure it's
that and [__] goddamn Trump I'd say
this summer
the King dies and [__]
Brent has to take his place
[Applause]
can I bring my cat
this whole thing is a [__] Adam said
Rob Schneider's in the back hey what's
up King just
[Music]
wait how many views does this have
183 000 views that's nothing
that that should that that just goes to
show you that it I mean we get more
views on this podcast you know
ah
God Britain people just need to [__]
give it up huh
Give It Up
a giant penis was mowed into the grass
at the site of a carnation party
okay give it up
a huge [__] and balls did really good
too
looks really nice
that's so good dude bro the king
coronation you know
this is like the music that should
happen when you walk into Universal
[__] Studios oh dude I yeah I present
you but get out of here with your dry
[__] you know yeah
[Music]
playing times
oh it's so [__] I hear present to
you King Charles
God's taking charge
tomorrow
dude this is a [__] Adam Sandler's
movie waiting to happen you know the
average Center just like have ad yes
I'll be the king you know
[Music]
uh yeah I'll be the king can can I bring
my cat you know
[Music]
whatever
wow dude this sucks huh like just
straight up
for at least
2020 [__] [__] free
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
uh yeah
can I bring my cat you know
[Music]
to you